[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday the 10th of
june
i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
on this week's show joe biden and boris
johnson meet today as the g7 summit gets
underway
what will they talk about and has the
phrase special relationship lost its
meaning
we'll be joined by the uk's former
ambassador to the states sir christopher
meyer
it comes as the conservative party
bickers about cuts to foreign aid
we'll be joined by two tories from
opposite sides of the debate
tim lorton and lee rowley plus an
england cricketer has been suspended for
sexist and racist tweets he made when he
was a teenager
is cancelled culture out of control
we'll speak to douglas murray
cova cases in the uk are rising but so
are the numbers of people who have been
vaccinated
with jabs now on offer to 25 year olds
should we be worried about a third wave
edinburgh university's professor roland
kao who sits on the government's
modeling advisory board will
be on the show and finally gb news
starts this weekend and its chair is
someone who you will be most familiar
with
andrew neil is back to tell us what to
expect
all that to come in the next hour but
before we get going if you enjoy what we
do on spectator tv
then subscribe to our youtube channel
click the button at the bottom of this
video and then tap the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode
and if you want to subscribe to the
magazine take up our 12 issues for 12
pound offer
you'll get three months worth of the
spectator in print and online for just
12 pounds
plus we'll give you a 20 pound amazon
voucher completely free
sounds too good to be true it's because
it is and go to spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer to take it up
now first we learned today that joe
biden issued a formal reprimand to boris
johnson's government earlier this month
over their approach to tensions on the
irish border but the president seemed in
high spirits when he touched down in the
uk for the g7 yesterday
what do the two leaders want from the
summit and is the so-called special
relationship still a useful framework
i'm joined now by the spectator's deputy
editor freddie gray
former british ambassador to the u.s sir
christopher mayer and the spectator's
deputy political editor katie balls
freddie you write in this week's
magazine about the relationship between
boris johnson and joe biden who will
both be gracing the world stage at the
g7
what do you think boris's approach will
be to the still fairly new president
i think it'll be a charm offensive uh
and i think everybody
uh on both sides the american side and
the british side uh
are keen to sort of forget about trump
to put the the trump presidency down the
memory hole
uh and pretend it didn't really ever
happen uh however i do think
there's a slight disconnect between the
british side and the american side and
how they're approaching each other
i think that um team boris uh
are very keen to sort of stress the uh
the things that biden and boris have in
common uh the shared
interests and agenda and of course
there's a lot of truth in that
um but i think as far as i can discern
from people in biden world
um they're still a little bit suspicious
of this slightly trumpy as they see him
figure
this populist um this brexiteer which is
they are instinctively very anti-brexit
so i think for all the happy talk
uh there's a sort of fundamental
misalignment
christopher you were britain's
ambassador to the u.s between 1997 and
2003.
what tends to happen at these kinds of
meetings well an awful lot of
preparation
for this summit has already happened i
mean people
called sherpas have been beavering away
uh drafting
communiques uh joint statements and all
that kind of stuff
it's an awful lot of the heavy lifting
has been done what remains for the
leaders
is to cross the t's and dot the eyes on
on
various uh on on some of these these
statements now
the question is whether something's
going to come out of left field during
the meeting that will force them
actually to have a really spontaneous
discussion of the issues and i'm not
quite sure
what what that might be i think i think
on what freddie just said
i think he's quite right to point out
that there will be suspicion in the
biden team
um about boris i mean in fact you know
boris could go anywhere in the world and
people would either react with suspicion
or with incredulity that such a guy
on some people's terms has managed to
become prime minister of the united
kingdom
but all that said if you regard
uh biden secretary of state tony blinken
as being somebody very close to the
president who knows the president's mind
i would say that the british team must
have been enormously encouraged
by lincoln's visit to london i think it
was at the beginning of may he did a
joint press conference
uh with dominic rob the secretary of
state
and out of the lips of tony blinken
came one of the most fulsome
endorsements i have
ever heard in my whole life and career
of the so-called special relationship uh
and i think blinking said something to
the effect that um
the united states has no closer ally now
if you regard lincoln as a harbinger of
biden
that's good news and if we are planning
on that basis
um i don't think it's too unrealistic
there have been some reports today that
it wasn't all rosy that the president
reprimanded boris johnson for his
handling
of the irish border the american side is
denying that
putting that to the side katie what do
you think boris johnson is hoping to get
out of the g7
i mean quite a few things i think the
fact that's happening in person
uh is already seen as an early victory
for boris johnson because
he has had to spend much of his time
since winning that majority of 80
trying to build bonds over zoom and
everyone around the prime minister will
say he doesn't work very well and zoom
compared to in person and so i think
that ultimately trying to shore up these
new relations with
uh other leaders is going to be key i
think the biden
first meeting is seen as very important
i mean we'll talk more about the fact
that boris johnson doesn't like the
sound of the phrase special relationship
but he still wants that relationship to
be special
and strategically number 10 i think i
put a lot of thought into how to make
sure
um when you take into account the fact
that uh the uk and the us have lots in
common strategically
and they personally will be able to
interact well things they can talk about
christopher boris johnson apparently
takes exception to the phrase
special relationship i have to admit i
love it but you've written today that
he's right
what was your experience of the way
these two countries work together and
why don't you think it's a helpful term
well first of all i just want to very
quickly pick up something
uh which uh which freddie said and it's
in his excellent article in the
in the latest edition of the spectator
in which he
he he he you know
the the question of whether there is a
problem in
the biden camp and particularly with the
president himself
with the rather rude things that have
been said in the past about brexit and b
about johnson
uh personally i wouldn't worry about
that at all i believe that joe biden as
a politician is
infinitely flexible and we have seen
that in the in the history of his of his
political operations
if someone like kamala harris who
excoriated
have existed biden in the democratic
primaries
can be invited by joe to become his vice
president
then anything can be forgiven so the
baggage of the past i think
will not be an issue down in cornwall
as to the special relationship the
problem with it
and this is why i wrote the piece i did
today saying that boris is right
to say to the president can you can you
soft pedal a bit please on this special
relationship stuff
and the americans have already adjusted
their language actually to take account
of that
things that i think jake sullivan said
even even today
is because the special relationship had
become
in the us uk relationship uh like a
like a holy grail like like a holy relic
um uh uh pickled an aspect if you can be
pickled in aspect
um it was a thing to be to be to be
worshipped you
stuck on your mental piece and say look
at that wonderful special relationship
it didn't do anything it didn't do what
a relationship is supposed
to do which is to advance the national
interest of the two countries that
subscribe to the notion
of being special and that is why i think
what you're going to see
coming out of this summit is a kind of
modernized version of the special
relationship
which will no longer be a memorial to
winston churchill and fdr
but uh but an operating live thing again
tony blinken uh when he was in london in
the beginning of may
said it is a dynamic thing and it's a
useful thing
well dynamic and useful i can live with
but with the the notion of this
of it being like a beautiful vars an end
in itself not the means to an end
that is what has become uh objectionable
and i think boris is quite right
to work against that old vision
christopher do you think domestic
politics in the u.s are going to affect
the way that boris and biden interact
obviously at some point somebody's going
to broach the topic of a trade deal
but it's hard enough at the moment to
see domestic policy getting across the
floor in the u.s
let alone international well i i have to
say that if i was in the british
government now
i wouldn't advise prime minister to
press that hard on a uk us trade
agreement
because i think it's going to be very
difficult to negotiate with the best
will in the world
there are a number of very very thorny
issues and sometimes i ask myself
given the richness of the mutual
investment and mutual trade that goes on
anyway
how necessary such an agreement might be
i mean i think a few months ago
when when this when this government was
young um
the the hard brexiteers extreme brexit
is very keen to achieve such an
agreement but it would show that
brexit is a success that kind of
neediness
is i think no longer present and i think
it would be very hard to get
to get through even with us a thin
democratic majority would be very hard
to get through
uh the us congress and for the president
to get what is known as fast-track
authorization for such an agreement
which means you can't fiddle around the
detail you can only approve it
or disapprove it up or down and it also
would be difficult to get so i wouldn't
be
i wouldn't be too fussed about about
about this
agreement more important if i can just
make this point
is the fact that even as these guys meet
bilaterally and in plenary there is a
living physical
embodiment of the 21st century
relationship between britain and america
sailing towards the south china seas
namely the so-called uh
task force group led by the british
flagship hms elizabeth this gigantic
aircraft carrier on which are over a
couple of hundred
u.s marines u.s fast jets
um and other and a us escort vessel
among
among others there is the modern
embodiment
of uh of the special relationship if you
like
and the interesting thing will be when
this when this attack i think it's
called an attack
group actually sounds a bit menacing
reaches
the indo-pacific region the the epithet
at the moment
the question will be how aggressively it
will pass through the south china seas
and will it or won't it go through the
taiwan straits
now that is something for biden and and
uh johnson to discuss i wouldn't i
wouldn't be too
fussed about the trade agreement thank
you katie freddie and christopher
now the g7 summit comes at a slightly
awkward time for the prime minister
his government is trying to cut foreign
aid spending from 0.7
to 0.5 percent of gdp the debate has
split the conservative party
and the government has avoided a vote on
the issue against the common speaker's
wishes
two tory mps on opposite sides of this
question join me now
tim lorton is the mp for east worthing
in shoreham he is against the cuts
and lee rowley is the mp for north
derbyshire and the deputy chair of the
conservative party
he supports the cuts thanks both for
joining me
lee you support the government's
decision to cut foreign aid spending can
you outline the case for us
yeah i know colleagues feel extremely
strongly about this and
rightly so the question for me when
uh looking at what the chancellor
brought forward a number of months ago
was did it seem reasonable and
proportionate
even in a very important area of public
spending
and i think given the extraordinary
circumstances that we're in
it is reasonable and proportionate to
what the government is doing i get that
people will not necessarily
like some of that and i get that there
is challenge but
overall most people in my constituency
are saying that this is a reasonable
thing to do and i
broadly agree with them tim you've said
that the decision will mean
condemning to death tens of thousands of
children from diseases like
the measles and malaria why isn't the
government receptive to this argument do
you think
well i think the government's in a
tricky position obviously the finances
uh are pretty precarious because of the
pandemic
but this is affecting the whole world
and look i was an mp
who very proudly voted for that 0.7
commitment
uh in the first place and we have had a
manifesto commitment
on it ever since and i stand by that
manifesto
commitment i think that's really uh
important
secondly this is a flexible formula it's
not as though we are still going to give
15 billion pounds or 20 billion pounds
or 10 billion pounds
it goes up when our economy is doing
well and it goes down
when we're struggling as we are at the
uh at the moment so effectively this is
a double whammy
that we're inflicting on people who are
in a precarious position
already so we're reducing the amount
because of the formula
and now we're reducing the formula
further so
it's it's i'm afraid it just doesn't
work and at a time when we desperately
need to be helping people
even more desperate than us tim how do
you address
waste a 2019 report from the institute
of economic affairs
found that tens of millions of pounds
were being spent through the foreign aid
budget
exporting nanny state programs this
included over a million pounds for a
research project in india
using text messages to persuade people
to drink less alcohol
nearly 350 000 pounds evaluating the
sugar tax
in chile it's revelations like these
that frustrate taxpayers and make one
question if there should always be
a guaranteed amount of funding for
foreign aid if it's not obviously being
spent in the right places
i entirely get that and and we could
reel off a whole load of other
um pretty dodgy projects the ethiopian
spy skills and things like
that over the years um and that is
wasteful spending and
the money should be going to really
important effective
uh schemes rather than that but these
are
a few small projects and in the
bigger scheme of things these are not
the things that are really going to be
uh
in impacted this is over four billion
pounds
which now means that we are going to be
seriously cutting
something like 80 for clean water
projects in uh in africa in the middle
of a uh pandemic
taking 25 percent out of girls education
one of the government's absolutely right
top
priorities for overseas um aid the food
programme
in starving uh yemen this is where it
will really have the uh
of the impact lee it's not a great look
is it on the international stage when
other countries are stepping up their
percentage of spending for the uk to be
cutting it
well even with this change even with
this reduction
the uk will still spend 10 billion
pounds this year
it will still spend more than france it
will still spend more than austria it
will still spend
more than greece more than spain more
than italy
more than australia will still spend
something like two and a half times more
proportionately
compared to the united states and so we
just have to be quite
careful in terms of the debate in the uk
about which is where we've effectively
got to about whether we're spending a
gargantuan amount of money
or an incredible amount of money and
whatever happens
uh in terms of the next few months and
what the government does and the
government has been cleared it's
intending to move to 0.5 for this
financial year
we will still be one of the leading
contributors of aid
all around the world so for those people
who are very passionate about this and
very committed to it
they can be proud of the united
kingdom's contribution this year as they
can be proud of it
in previous years but we can also accept
that the contribution the united kingdom
is making is reflecting the extremely
challenging
circumstances at home and recognizing
that the majority of people who are sat
at home who
are watching this or watching other
discussions on other parts of the media
about it
are in the headspace that there is a
recognition that our spending in many
areas not just this
needs to reflect the circumstances which
we're in
lee what do you make of the way the
government has handled this question
the government says it has no plans to
bring forward a vote on these cuts
despite the common speakers saying that
there really should be a vote
it's clear that if there were it might
be a sticky situation for the government
are they just going to avoid the
question altogether
well i don't think the you know there's
a huge amount of opportunity within the
parliamentary calendar to hold the
government to account one more example
was yesterday i was trying to get in and
debate yesterday and
ran out of time i would have appreciated
a little bit more time so
yesterday so some more of us could have
spoken um but that was the speaker's
choice
so you know there is an enormous amount
of time for us as parliamentarians to
have
these discussions questions written
questions or like i get that there is a
desire
in parts of parliament for this to be
taken to a vote we will have to see
where that
goes but you know i think the government
has set out its stall pretty clearly and
parliament is able to respond
should it wish tim last question d to
you do you think the government wants to
hear your voice on this
well i think what the government should
uh
be saying itself all the time is what a
fantastic job
the british government cursive british
shakespeare has done over many
years now and we don't get enough credit
for her
for that um but we
there are lots of really good projects
which we can all be
really really proud of and i want my
constituents to see more of those
because as lee says you know some of the
opinion polls say that people actually
would prefer the money to be spent at
home but actually when you show them
how this money is spent when you ask
them the question about do you
actually think we should be spending
taxpayers money on saving lives and food
programs in
uh in yemen or medical programs in north
africa or whatever
i think most reasonable people will say
well probably uh actually yes
and the more evidence we can show of the
good that it does and we are privileged
as mps to be able to
go and visit some of these projects and
see uh just
uh the the amazing results that they're
they're producing i want
i want the government to sing more about
uh about that and so
it's just so out of character for us
to step back at a time when we need to
be stepping up and frankly for the sake
of four billion pounds
it's a lot of money but we've spent over
400 billion pounds in the pandemic so
we're talking about one percent of the
extra money we've had to
come up with quite rightly for the uh
for the pandemic
but that four billion the leverage that
it produces the gearing it produces in
terms of
of save lives if of growing economies
uh saving uh people in desperate
circumstances
from from ending up with people
traffickers or whatever
and promoting uk plc and opening trade
links
and huge amount of goodwill and standing
that it brings for the uk in the
in the world particularly post brexit is
worth hugely more than four billion
pounds this is why i think it's a hugely
forced economy to be doing this
well a follow-up to the last question
tim uh as you say it's
it's a drop in the ocean compared to
what has been spent on the kova crisis
so far
but of course we're looking at huge
budget deficit skyrocketing debt because
of what's had to be done
for the kova crisis at some point the
government might have to start
discussing trade-offs
so if you want the money to be spent in
one area like foreign aid
don't you think it's time the government
starts talking about what it might be
willing to cut so that we can pay for it
well we're going to be facing some some
very serious uh
challenges and decisions as to how we
get the economy back on
uh back on track post the pandemic now
hope we need to see
just how quickly the economy is going to
be able to bounce back the signs are
really encouraging uh how much tax
revenue we can get back into the
exchequer to start paying off some of
these
these debts but in the in the next few
years
the balance sheet is going to be looking
uncomfortable after all the good work
that the
uh coalition and then conservative
governments have done to try and get our
finances back into
shape the pandemic is completely not
that for six but
we're not alone in that that's happened
to the whole world and i think we are in
a stronger position because of the
action that the government has taken
to protect and preserve jobs and
businesses so that when we're through it
they can bounce uh bounce back rather
than have to be completely started up
all over
uh again that's how we will pay these uh
these these bills but for the sake of
four billion pounds as i say which is
i think worth far more in terms of what
it brings to the uh
uh to the uk we risk losing an
awful lot of uh of goodwill and standing
but most importantly
uh we risk a devastating impact on some
of those people that
absolutely need our help and have
depended on it thank you liam thank you
tim
next the cricketer ollie robinson was
suspended from the england team last
week after it emerged that he had put
out racist and misogynistic tweets when
he was a teenager
he released a video apologizing for the
comments have a look
on the biggest day of my career so far
i'm embarrassed by the racist and sexist
tweets that i've posted over eight years
ago
which have today become public i want to
make it clear that i'm not racist and
i'm not sexist
i deeply regret my actions and i'm
ashamed of making such remarks
i was thoughtless and irresponsible and
regardless of my state of mind at the
time
my actions weren't usable since that
period i've matured
as a person and fully regret the tweet
today should be about my efforts on the
field and the pride of making my test
debut
but my thoughtless behaviour in the past
has tarnished this
so does the punishment fit the crime or
is this another example of cancer
culture getting out of control
to discuss i'm joined by douglas murray
the spectator's associate editor
and james forsyth the spectator's
political editor james can you talk us
through what happened
so ollie robinson is a 27 year old
cricketer now plays for sussex
and he made his england debut uh in uh
last week's test match between
england and new zealand uh he took a
couple of wickets but at the end of the
first day's play
it came out that when he was a kind of
18 19 year old
he sent a bunch of crass tweets um
bad tastes jokes uh and
that was particularly embarrassing for
the ecb because the england world's
quick board
because all the players before the game
had lined up wearing kind of
anti-discrimination
t-shirts then at the end of the match in
which
uh robinson was probably one of
england's better players uh the ecb
announced that they were suspending
robinson from all international cricket
pending an investigation i think what is
particularly tough here
is that robinson is is now 27
and he didn't have an easy start to his
cricketing career and he was sacked by
yorkshire uh because of kind of poor
timekeeping and general bad attitude
so while he hasn't been punished
specifically for the tweets that he sent
you know he has paid a price for that
phase in his life
and the kind of general lack of
seriousness
in his approach to life and i think
that's why the ecb's punishment
feels disproportionate douglas robison
has explicitly apologized for the tweets
which he admits were wrong you've
written that this saga shows that we are
unforgiving in the way our society is
treating people now
what do you mean by that well the first
thing is as james just referred to the
fact that this should be done on what
would have been
uh robinson's proudest day of his career
to date
his first day playing for england
in such a test match and i think it's
for a lot of people it just looks like
an extraordinarily
retributive thing to do the timing is so
vengeful and going back to what james
just referred to in the actual story
we're talking about
tweets from 10 years ago uh
bad taste jokes basically banter
from a young man who seemed not to
realize that twitter
was not a medium to communicate with
your mates but was a
broadcasting medium to the whole world
these tweets by the way at the time
weren't even picked up i mean they got
sort of one
and two likes and things like that
so they didn't gain him anything but
here they are 10 years later looking
like they could crash his career
the reason i say that there's something
deeply vengeful about it and disturbing
about it
is not just that element of it but
what's expected afterwards
he was invited to read out a prepared
statement before the camera in a scene
which i
thought looked positively
pyongyang-esque
as he read out his formal apology
expressed how
into diversity he actually is and so on
he was he was a young man basically sort
of begging for his
career and then uh he was suspended
anyway
that's what i find so disturbing about
it it's not just
the sort of archaeological offense uh
business
it's just the fact that as i've written
quite a lot before
we live in a society that's really good
on the vengeance it's
really good on the offense archaeology
it's really good at punishing people
for airing once in a statement but we've
spent
no time thinking about how people are
meant to redeem themselves
yeah i think douglas is a very fair
point though which is ollie robinson
doesn't try and defend his remarks
and he didn't make these remarks as an
england cricketer and i mean there is a
question about you know how far
back we go but there's another case now
involving an unnamed christian
and tweets he sent before the age of 16.
so
how far back into people's past are we
going
i also think there's there's an element
here of a lack of media
savviness you know i i think i think if
if robinson had had
uh maybe a more worldly wise
agent around him for example he'd have
said to him look you're going to get a
lot more media attention playing for
england than you do play for sussex so
i suggest you just delete all that
social media stuff you know
whatever let's not bother going back
through it to see what's there
just just delete it all i mean that's
going to become a much more common
reaction
uh from people when they know that
they're about to be propelled to sudden
fame
one of the other things by the way about
this it's so disturbing i think is this
is this assumption that i mean you know
our cricketers our sportsmen
uh um you know they if they represent
the national team they do represent the
nation in some way but
they're not a clerical class i mean i
know some people
in sports these days seem to think that
they are and think that they have to
effectively preach to the terraces
but they're not a clerical class and i
have a question over
why it is that we expect them to be
these sorts of
purer than pure figures i mean uh
um we have a situation at the moment
where uh there are mps in parliament who
are actually in our legislative bodies
who have said much worse things than
ollie robinson did ollie robinson did
this
this bad taste banter 10 years ago less
time ago than that
zara sultana the labour mp was tweeting
out anti-jewish racist remarks on
twitter
uh now now i'm much more disturbed by by
racists uh um
racist twitter histories in the house of
commons then i am
inappropriate banter from members of the
england cricket team
but it seems to be so easy to sort of
crush
a young cricketer's career um hound some
sportsman or woman
uh and and i think there's something
completely off about this i don't look
to the england cricket team for morality
or ethics or behavior
i don't want any of that from i don't
want it from the terraces i don't want
it from the football teams james let's
get into the politics of this
douglas raises the double standard point
but ministers are now getting involved
culture secretary oliver dowden said
that the cricket board went over the top
in its decision to suspend
robinson do you think he should be
intervening i i
i must admit i am wary about both
uh both sport getting into politics and
politics getting into sport i mean i
mean there's a
but i think i mean i don't that is where
this gets
gets tricky i think it would be much
healthier
if there was less politics in sport and
politicians were taking less of an
interest in this
kind of question um you know i mean
there are there are various companies
around the world whereas points in their
history where
you know where where the national
governments have leaned quite heavily on
the selection of the of
a of the cricket team and the like i
mean that would obviously be
an absurd route to go down but i think
there is something going on here which
is
the the reaction just does seem so
disproportionate seeing that robinson
seems to be
genuinely contrite for what he said and
and i think there is a question here
as i said how do we do forgiveness at
what point can someone say
something that is regarded as being
enough and and you know
and i think having your test match debut
the proudest moment of your career to
date
you know um spoiled in this way i mean
that seems like a fairly hefty
punishment already
let's open this up slightly more widely
because it's not just oliver dowden who
jumped into the culture wars this week
gavin williamson also waded into a
debate
over an oxford college that wants to
take down a picture of the queen
is this part of number 10 strategy now
james that they're going to weigh into
the culture wars more
and perhaps they're not going to wait
for labor to prompt them to do so
i i think the government's attitudes of
culturals has always been
to wait uh to be responsive to wait for
for something to happen that most people
will consider silly this oxford row is
spectacularly stupid
uh or you know you've got the middle
combination room at modeling college
oxford deciding to remove a picture of
the queen on the basis that you know
you can't disentangle her from uh the
state from colonialism
and if you want to go down this argument
about you know historical privilege and
all this
i think you i think you would argue that
it's impossible to disentangle modeling
college oxford from it by that logic
they should remove themselves um so it
is an um
it is a truly absurd route but i also
think that you know
that the government wading into it has a
certain saviness to it because
student student unions let alone middle
combination rooms
have done dark things throughout history
and and
in some ways there can't be that much i
think
i think it is a remarkable spectacular
level of interest
but this gesture and it is a gesture has
generated
it's it's a very interesting question
this
about the the uh culture wars and the
government uh putting into it because
there's something that i think a lot of
our viewers will be aware of that go
goes on here
the left fights vicious sectarian
culture wars
on a daily basis and then whenever
anyone of the right
does anything pushing back there are two
moves that the radical left makes
they either say oh how dare you play a
culture war
or they say you're playing a culture war
against the problem that doesn't exist
which happens to be manifested daily in
their own behavior
and so when when people sort of get into
this whole sort of does
should government get engaged in it the
answer is
that the government should stand up for
the traditions and the people of the
united kingdom
you know the the government of the
united kingdom is not an ngo
it's not a a mere distributor of funds
in a multi-national level
it is the government of the united
kingdom it should stand up for the
traditions and the
the good history of our country i think
it is
often the case that there are silly
things i agree the malden college
portrait is a relatively silly case
because you can always find students
doing dumb
stuff but nevertheless when there are
serious questions over
publicly funded institutions and the
ideological drift of them
then it isn't inappropriate i think uh
for ministers and others to take an
interest you know in a generational long
leftward drift which would be good to
see stopped
douglas some thought that brexit and
donald trump were fueling the culture
wars and the dial down of the event
and the man might allow for some
breathing space but
culture wars seem to have a much longer
shelf life than many would have thought
that's right that's right i i never
bought that argument that you know
donald trump would leave office and uh
the radical left in america would stop
pushing you know i i never
bought that i think it's the same in the
uk there's
there's a particular ideological agenda
which the radical left has it's the same
agenda around the world they're always
pushing for the same boring things
and um everywhere the right is slightly
stymied in what its response should be
there are perfectly reasonable responses
the right can play back
but but yeah and the the it's not as if
the ideological left was ever planning
to take a break
uh simply because uh joe biden's in
office or because uh
the brexit agreement had been reached
james on the other side trump certainly
used the culture wars to his advantage
now that he's gone is there just a
gaping trump-sized hole that others are
trying to fill
or is there room for calmer conversation
now between the two sides to discuss how
they might tackle the big issues of the
day
i i think the remarkable thing when you
look at uh polling in the uk
is how small the kind of cultural
numbers are and i think i think i think
that douglas is right about
where most of this starts and i think it
generally tends to start with uh a small
number of kind of
highly committed activists on the left
who push for a bunch of things and then
you get some pushback
and i think that but i think we i think
in a way one of the things
the answer to all of these problems to
my mind is
more education not less um
let's have a debate about the statues in
this country
but let's not rip them down let's
understand why they are there in the
first place
what they represent why people at the
time admired them
why people today might think differently
and i think that you know
contextualization
is is a much better approach to this
stuff that
than than trying to silence your
opponent
pull down statues no platform people i
think we can
but i i think i think actually in the
general public there is there is
there is far more agreement on cultural
questions
uh that than you might think i think
that most people broadly accept that
this country has
been a force for good in the world but
it has a long history some of which is
inglorious and some of which is glorious
and i think that i mean the the public
understanding of these
these questions actually kind of much
more nuanced often than the elite
understanding
can i just because i agree with james
but just with one caveat if i made
about the polling of the public
understanding of culture wars as james
knows there's been a
several polls recently a yougov poll and
ipsos mario poll on these issues
and and they've been used by a number of
people from right and left to say the
the public doesn't really care about
culture wars issues and the reason that
people have claimed that about this
recent polling
is the relatively low number of people
who for instance particularly care
either way about particular trans
issues now there's an obvious reason for
that which is there's a very small
number of trans people in society and
the issue is directly affecting
relatively few people in any direction
so it's sort of understandable the the
reason i wanted to add the caveat is
that the exception in this is a very
high level of public awareness and
dissatisfaction
of the racialization of the rhetoric
specifically
the use of white as a pejorative term
the
lumping in of all white people into one
case into one
racial category and a negative racial
category at that
that's very interesting to me because it
suggests that
in a white majority country the majority
of people
have picked up on the fact that in the
culture war
there are things being said now of a
racially reprehensible nature
which rub the majority up the wrong way
and if i were the radical left
uh pushing some of this cultural stuff
at the moment i would look at those
polls and begin to worry
well douglas and james thank you for
joining me for that conversation
james before we let you go we're going
to be talking about covet 19
later on in the show and a lot of our
viewers are going to be wondering about
what their summer is going to look like
i've written about my nostalgia for the
spontaneous social life in this week's
magazine
what is the government's latest thinking
on easing lockdown restrictions
when we get to the 21st of june are we
finally going to be free
so we'll get a decision taken you know
that they'll be meet discussions
this weekend um and then we'll get a
decision on monday
on on the 14th on what is going to
happen on the 21st
and i think at the moment things are on
a knife edge i think that things are
moving
slightly in favor of a short delay
depending on
because of the importance of the second
dose of the vaccine
against the indian variant i think there
is a there is a thought that if you
allowed
you know everyone in priority groups one
to nine who account for 99
of covert deaths to have had their
second dose and achieve the kind of
extra immunity that you gain from that
then you would be safer to go ahead with
them with a more
comprehensive unlocking uh i think i
think is
i think someone said to me the the the
question now is
you know is we know that we is we know
that the
vaccines have severely weakened the link
between cases and hospitalizations the
question now is
how severely have they broken it
entirely in which case it would be
safe to go ahead with a full unlocking
on june 21st
or is it still there albeit in much
reduced form
in which case i think you might see
things like the one meter rule
uh continuing for a little while longer
one other issue i
i would add here kate is that i think it
is inevitable that when you lift
all restrictions there will be an
increase in cases
so there's also another factor to
consider here which is when do you want
to
have that and given that uh
the summer months are generally when
there is the least pressure on the nhs
it it might be worth having your exit
wave in summer
rather than in autumn or winter thank
you james and so on to covet
cases are continuing to rise as the
delta variant becomes the uk's dominant
coronavirus strain
but with a successful vaccine rollout
now meaning 80 percent of british adults
have antibodies to the virus
have we broken that link between cases
hospitalizations and deaths
and can the 21st of june's freedom day
go ahead
i'm joined now by professor roland cao
from the university of edinburgh
who sits on spy m the government's
modeling advisory board
professor thank you so much for joining
me to start the big question on
everybody's mind is whether or not the
21st of june is going to go ahead
in your professional opinion and through
your work in the government's modeling
unit
what advice would you be giving to the
prime minister
it is very finely tuned at the moment
and one of the issues that's been coming
up lately is that
the number of hospitalizations do appear
to be increasing
and that is a warning sign that that um
delaying
may be worthwhile um obviously that only
considers the epidemiological aspects
um and it is for others to decide
whether or not that epidemiology alone
is something that's worth um making a
decision on
when the government is feeling
optimistic its rhetoric tends to be
about making sure
that vaccines outpace the virus yet you
can tell they're getting worried when
they start talking about how vaccines
aren't 100
effective it's an odd talking point
given that nobody thought we'd reach
that standard and the vaccines we have
have an excellent efficacy rate they
seem to be falling back on that latter
message now
so perhaps that's bad news for reopening
i think the thing to keep in mind is all
the initial data on the vaccine efficacy
was for um the original type of virus
and what we now call the alpha variant
so those are the types that were
prevalent prior to this april
um the revised estimates of vascine
efficacy show that the delta variant
is somewhat different and in particular
individuals who only have had
one dose of either of the vaccines that
we use
are only partially protected and that
really
unfortunately does seem to change the
potential scenarios
you told the times about a week ago that
if hospitalizations and death rates stay
low
then all fine but if we did start to see
them go up then that would be a reason
to delay reopening
what numbers are we talking about
because we know as we have more activity
infections and sadly hospitalizations
and deaths will go
up but it's about keeping numbers
relatively low compared to those peaks
certainly at the end of the day it's
going to be true that we
have to accept that some people will get
severely ill and some people will die of
covet 19
almost no matter what we do and it's
really about
will things get so bad that we need to
do something
different unfortunately it does look
like
that the information on the deaths alone
will be very hard to come by
so hospitalization numbers are
increasing i mean the good news if you
want to call it that
is that the death numbers of deaths are
uncertain at the moment okay which
indicates at the very least
there isn't a severe effect of this
variant on
increasing death rates but it doesn't
mean that there isn't enough of an
increase
enough for an increase in people going
into
intensive care for example also being an
issue
that they don't merit some change and
the biggest thing of course
is the state of the hospitals and the
nhs the cover article for this week's
spectator
written by professor philip thomas says
that we are already in the middle of a
third wave
a worrying thought but he says this
isn't a reason to delay the 21st of june
and his reasoning is that we're seeing
that break in infections and
hospitalizations
and that people who are currently
getting infected are mostly the
unvaccinated
the young who are significantly less
likely to have a severe reaction to the
virus
what do you make of that
so there's a few things to think about
there first of all we always knew that
as restrictions were released that it
was likely we'd see more infections
in the absence of the delta variant it
seemed like those
um rises in cases for precisely the
reasons that you mentioned
were likely to be acceptable okay that
we could we could get through it
without that severe impact we would
balance off the risk and say that
okay that we will accept that this is
gonna happen we don't like it
it's gonna be bad for the people who are
being affected but overall
it's the best thing for us as a society
the problem with the delta varies is it
changes the equation quite a bit and one
of the things you have to remember is
that
as i mentioned earlier that the number
of deaths have
not yet been affected because there's
always a lag and the other thing to keep
in mind
is that thus far the total number of
cases is still low
okay and that's a result of the
combinations of the restrictions that
everybody works so hard to keep up
over the winter the increased effects of
vaccination
both of those things having a big effect
so what we're likely to see in the
future
is is further spread and one of the
crucial facts about this is that as you
see that
greater amount of spread uh what we call
the infection pressure so the
probability
per person that infection will transmit
to them will increase
all right it'll vary by space and
geography
as well also vary by by social groups
but overall you will see that rise and
what that means is those people who are
partially protected
will see you'll see greater risks in
them and greater chances that they will
become infected
so remember that the people who have the
first dose in particular
are probably on the order of and
estimates do vary and they vary between
the two vaccines but on the order of
50 percent protected and so their
chances of getting infected remain high
so the crucial question the absolutely
crucial question remains
will they get severely ill and will they
be at high risk of dying
and sadly it's what we don't know yet
and so
the argument for potentially delaying
the release of restrictions that
even a few more weeks one will give us a
better ability to assess that
give time to vaccinate more and more
people because we're
the really good news is that it looks
like two vaccine doses has a much better
protection
give us that opportunity to get more
people vaccinated move
into the summer holiday period and
therefore get to the point where
the risk over the summer remain low
enough so that we can
safely move forward and just to break
this down and clarify
when you talk about relatively large
groups of the population that are still
vulnerable do you mean they're
vulnerable to getting the virus
are we talking about groups that you
think were in those vulnerable
categories that haven't been vaccinated
at all or perhaps have only had one dose
and so they aren't as fully protected as
they could be because the government has
insisted that everybody who would be
really vulnerable
the most statistically likely to end up
in hospitals suffering severe illness
from this
have had the opportunity to get the
vaccine certainly people are doing
as much as they can and you know the nhs
has done a really good job in
making the vaccine roll up better than
we would have expected
what we do know from other pieces of
evidence is that that vaccine update
as i was mentioning earlier in the
conversation is variable
okay so there's some some groups of
individuals some of them in certain
ethnic groups
uh in some ways related to deprivation
and some of the
issues here are about things like access
for example
as well as personal choice those are the
groups where there's more likely to be
lower vaccine uptake
okay now the thing that we still don't
know is the extent to which
we can catch those last groups and so
what you may end up with
is substantial portions of the
population in particular areas and these
are
remember deprivation is also linked to
higher
probabilities of severe illness but
fairly large numbers
in pockets who are highly vulnerable in
that sense
and we're not talking about small
numbers of individuals here
five percent of the population in
certain areas is still a good proportion
a large number of people and it's a
worrying thought that there would be
clusters of really vulnerable people who
might be badly impacted if they get this
virus
what more can the government do do you
think to get these people vaccinated
if you were saying this is a key group
of people as to whether or not we can
reopen
surely all the focus should be on making
sure these people get protected
if they want to and choose to do so
and certainly you know there is as we
know there are issues with
some individuals who who will refuse
vaccines
okay now the aim would be to um
as much as possible get the others who
may not have got it for all sorts of
reasons
um so it could be about access it could
be about communication
so for example missing appointments
because
you just don't have good access to get
it and things sort of moving forwards
you just need to make sure that the
numbers you get of the people who want
to
are high now i'm not a social scientist
so i'm not the person
to to talk to about what those
motivations might be but certainly there
are people who look at these things and
are
saying okay part of it is about
communication and part is about just
making it easier for people to do
and part of it's about follow-up what
would a delay to the 21st of june mean
for the winter months because the
implication if they push back the 21st
of june
is that that activity was particularly
risky
do you think there's a plausible
scenario where we see more restrictions
in the wintertime
it's something that we have to be
prepared for
nobody wants this okay nobody wants this
but the thing we need to be aware of are
a number of things when we don't
really know the duration of immunity
okay we know it lasts a certain amount
of time there's evidence
of good protection um for people being
immune either by natural infection
or from the vaccine for at least um
several months maybe up to six months
but remember by the time we hit next
winter the people who were initially
vaccinated were vaccinated
up to over a year before that all right
so then it becomes down to boosters
okay and getting enough boosters out
getting out in populations which maybe
is a little bit less
aware of code if in fact we get to the
point where the numbers have really gone
down
and of course we already know that
variants have the ability
to take all of our plans and blow them
out of the water
okay that's happened twice already
now all around the world coveted
spreading
with variable levels of vaccination
variable levels of control and that mix
of vaccinated and unvaccinated people in
different numbers
is is unfortunately the situation which
most promotes the development of these
variants
and so there will remain especially if
we don't do
maintain good restrictions good testing
at the borders
um a high probability that if a variant
were to rise elsewhere
that is of concern that it would spread
here and that again
can change our circumstances um we don't
want to see that happen
has it happened though because the
vaccines have been knocked by the
variants several times now but so far
they seem to be holding up
again we know anything could change as
the past 15 months have
shown us but so far they seem to be
holding up when it comes to
hospitalization
and death and crucially i mean those are
the two most important metrics to
measure
and so if they have held up all the data
for the uk in particular
seems to be quite positive it's the
country that wants to get vaccinated
most in the world yes there is some
vaccine hesitancy
but 90 of the population wants to be
vaccinated
the vaccines seem to be holding up we
continue to rank in the top five
countries for rate of vaccination
antibody prevalence is through the roof
it's estimated now that roughly 80
percent of adults in the uk have
antibodies
so if there's still these outstanding
questions about why we can't
meaningfully reopen
a lot of people will be sitting there
thinking to themselves should i just
start to prepare
for this being the new normal and us not
going back to the old one
now some people might be content with
that but others are just not going to be
able
to live with it so what is the data that
we need to see
change now or the updates that we need
to see to be able to say that we can
reopen and call it a day
so first of all just a clarification
when i say that the variants have
have changed our plans those are not um
escape mutants these are not the vaccine
of aiding variants
they're vague variants which changed our
response to the non-pharmaceutical
interventions
now the thing to keep in mind about the
the evolution of new types of the virus
is the evolution responds to the
circumstance the virus is in
okay so the virus essentially is a
random a random thing it doesn't have a
it doesn't choose in any intelligent way
the vaccine escape variance will only
arise when you have
large numbers of people who are
vaccinated and so the highly
vulnerable time for those variants to
arise
is precisely as the vaccine numbers are
ramping up
but where there's lots of infection now
remember britain
has what 65 odd 6
60 to 70 million people in it okay that
is a very small proportion of the entire
world
and so even if we have a very high level
of vaccination
um there is this issue that um elsewhere
in the world
is it's far more likely the variance
will rise
there not over here and so therefore our
wariness has to be over the entire globe
which is again
one of the reasons why a global
vaccination
program that makes sure that everybody
has that opportunity that we
are very fortunate to have isn't just an
issue of helping those countries it's
about helping us
last question professor do you think the
uk has gotten its vaccine policy
right do you think we should have been
shipping more vaccines
overseas earlier on to protect the most
vulnerable
around the world rather than
distributing them to 25 and 30 year olds
here at home
that is one of the great wicked problems
that we have isn't it on the one hand we
really do need to get things moving over
here you know we do have to have a
certain amount of we need to get the
country that we have moving forward
we also need to protect the rest of the
world i am not convinced it's an either
or
situation okay if if we had better
synchronization
okay synchronization is really the key
here
um and that requires cooperation working
with other countries around the globe
we can't actually do both all right so
it's not just about
numbers about how do you distribute it
what do you do to make sure that
vaccines are distributed but infection
is not and that's critical
thank you for joining me professor ko
and finally
gb news is starting at the weekend it's
chair and one of the presenters
is someone who might be familiar to a
few of you hi andrew
welcome back to spectator tv for those
that don't know could you tell them a
bit about what you've been up to over
the past few weeks
uh well in addition to my
responsibilities at the spectator i've
been
gearing up for the launch of gb news
britain's new news channel
which we hope is going to launch if all
the machinery will work at the same time
at 8 o'clock on june the 13th which is
this coming sunday from where we are
now it's a joy to be back on spectator
tv
and really annoying to see how well
you've done since i stopped appearing on
it
well i can tell you that the viewers
really have missed you andrew we still
get quite a few comments about it so i'm
glad we
cleared that up and now you can tell us
what we should expect from gb news when
it
launches next week is it going to be
obvious the ways that gb news is going
to set itself apart from the other
networks
i think it will i think people will
maybe take a little bit of time to get
used to what we're trying to be up to
what we want to be up to but i think it
will be different in two ways
one is it won't be rolling news there's
enough rolling news around at the moment
that's basically what sky does and
the bbc news channel as well and
rolling uses repetitive and uh because
it repeats a lot
the ratings have never been high for
ruling use you
get great ratings if there's a gulf war
or a pandemic breaking out
but then once that's over the rolling
news ratings are cnn and sky
and others have found out gone down so
we are not going to be that we're going
to be
much more a series of programs starting
at six in the morning till midnight
built round presenters with a bit of
attitude and
character bees in their bonnet
and so on so it's not so much
newsletters presenter
led with a wide variety of um
topics it's what american news channels
now do from fox on the right to msnbc on
the left and here's the news
they do rate well they do rate very well
if you get it right
and the second thing is that i think you
know i take the view don't
to it's not really controversial but
some people get annoyed
i think the existing incumbents the
people who provide
news and broadcast news in britain sky
bbc
channel 4 news itv they pretty much
all come from the same
stable of varying shades of center-left
attitudes
and in some it's almost like a one-party
state some
are more left than others channel 4 news
is more left than sky
sky these days remarkably i think is
more left than the bbc
uh bbc is a bit more left than itv which
is probably
the closest to the center and that
brings a set of attitudes
whether it's towards brexit or to cancel
culture
or even just an attitude towards britain
which is pretty much of a muchness and i
think we want to come
without going anywhere in the direction
of a fox news or anything like that
from perhaps a different agenda a
different set of assumptions
and looking at the world in a different
way outside that
cozy kind of tony blairish consensus
well social media is abuzz with the
launch and some people are already
convinced that they know
exactly what you're going to feature the
tone and the content
of a platform that hasn't yet launched
it must be very interesting defending
editorial decisions that haven't been
made yet
it's really interesting to defend
editorial positions that haven't been
made and i'm not quite sure what they'll
be
yet until we actually launched look the
buzzers have been fantastic about it i i
mean the one
you know whether it's positive or
negative i mean the the one thing
that you know i launched sky news as
part of the overall sky package way back
in 1989
and i do remember then it was the
the attitude was a combination either of
either hostility to the idea of a news
channel
particularly one owned by rupert murdoch
um or just
indifference you know what we need a
news channel for that that was actually
true in america when ted turner
launched cnn and i was with him the week
he launched cnn
and there was kind of indifference to
that too well we know what happened
there
this is very different there is a buzz
whether it's hostile or positive
there is quite a big buzz there's an air
of anticipation
uh about it as well and we have to
capitalize
on that people are going to be
interested so we better give them what
they're looking for
and do it in a way that this is going to
make them
stick so people are to a degree i did
not foresee
kate people whether it's to smackers or
praises
they are waiting to see the launch of
this channel
it's a competitive industry made more
difficult for the newcomer by the fact
that the biggest broadcaster doesn't
have to compete the bbc has laws that
protect its income and a mandatory
license fee
if you own a television is the way that
news has been done before
all these structures these systems is
that really fit for purpose now
especially as
um you know we have many more platforms
and people have so much more access to
what they choose to watch
well the bbc uh has its guaranteed
income which it tops up by over a
billion with its overseas sales and
commercial
uh ventures it i think it has a total
budget of about five billion
and even though its income is guaranteed
it does like to compete
uh i mean that sometimes or annoys itv
or sky
but it does compete i mean you couldn't
really argue that strictly come dancing
was a pinnacle of public service
broadcasting but it's a hell of a
ratings winner for the bbc so they do
like to compete
look i think the the the current license
fee structure is obviously
not fit for purpose in the decade that
we've now
entered and there will have to be
changes what they'll be is not for me to
get involved in uh i've got enough of my
hands
just uh running you lot of the spectate
you lot of the spectator i mean that's a
full-time job
that's like herding cats on its own
never mind running gb news
um but i would say to the
two things uh british broadcast
news that's that's the police coming for
me by the way we probably haven't paid
the rent
of the new studios british broadcast
news
is among the best in the world uh and
and is
highly regarded all over the world uh
our
our british broadcasting whether it's
the bbc or sky or
itn one of the most famous names
in it or even channel four and their
documentaries
we are highly regarded uh as
broadcasters i would say among
the best in the world so that's been a
good thing and
you know sky news was a great addition
the bbc
had to up its game sadly itv lost
interesting news that was a huge loss
because
when i was your age kate itn was a far
bigger news name than the bbc
music 10 on itv was my old mentor
alastair burnett
that was the newscast that mattered the
first half hour newscast
uh they were the first double-headed
newscast
massive ratings 12 million people in
these days used to tune in
but things need to change and
i don't think we can remain top of our
game without
reforms financing structures coming in
and changing and that's up to the bbc as
to how it goes forward with
charter renew his biggest mistake would
be to think he should just try
to hold on to the license fee as is
there will have to be changes
that's for them what i'm hoping we to
try and do is just bring a bit more
variety
a bit wider discourse a bit of a
different agenda or even when we cover
the same agenda to come
as subjects differently i'll just give
you a general
example there was a discussion on the
today program about a month ago
on the bbc radio uh which and as you
know like the second world war kate
the whole pandemic business has made big
government fashionable again
and you know big government the second
world war gave us the athlete government
which certainly believed
in big government and mr johnson seems
to believe in big government too so the
today program of this clever idea
of debating you know is big government
here to stay
good subject except that all four people
that were on that discussion believed in
big government
well i think gb news might manage to
find at least somebody to say
hey hold on the pandemic was the
pandemic
we need to get back to a more
jeffersonian
idea of more limited government again it
won't be easy but that's what we try to
do
it's just an example of it you will know
to the existing broadcasters
if there's a problem that they identify
in britain and boy
are they good at finding problems
sometimes problems don't even exist
but they're good at finding them they
come from a point of view which has
two suppositions in it one is if it's a
problem
it needs the government to resolve it
and secondly
if the government's to resolve it it
will need more money
so more government more money in some
cases
that may well be the way to resolve it
but not in every case
and i think we'll come at things just
that bit of a different way
which over time people will see is a
different kind of discourse and dialogue
to the existing incumbent news providers
well let me know if you find anybody of
the uh small state perspective and
government entry because they seem to be
swirly lacking
i think we have your number kate i think
we have you on speed dial
uh last uh last question andrew and i
think the one
that people want uh the answer to
the most will you still be making an
occasional appearance on spectator tv
yes i will but only if you ask me nicely
and next time
promise to provide the coffee i mean
we're delighted to hear it thank you
andrew thank you it's great to be back
and you're doing a great job good luck
with it
thanks andrew we'll be sure to take you
up on that offer and we'll see you soon
and that's it for this week if you've
enjoyed this episode why not subscribe
to the spectator's youtube channel so
you never
miss out just click the subscribe button
at the bottom of this video
and the bell icon so you don't miss our
episodes
thank you for watching and do join us
again next week bye
[Music]
you